[Musique]
quand j'étais petit je voulais être
musicien avoir un goût faire un tour du
monde et est une énorme rock star j'ai
grandi puis j'ai eu ma première société
je voulais qu'elle rayonne dans la
france entière et pourquoi pas
l'international
j'ai travaillé comme un acharné pour la
faire évoluer et sans forcément
apprécier l'instant présent il y avait
des moments où c'était bien des moments
où tu bossais comme un taré et au final
tu oublié l'essentiel
le problème c'est quand on en veut
toujours plus on finit par oublier en
réalité ce qu'on a déjà
le secret c'est de savoir saisir
l'instant et savoir saisir le bonheur
savoir se contenter de ce qu'on a et pas
toujours vouloir plus parce qu'en
réalité la plupart des gens se font une
fausse idée du bonheur
on pense tous que le bonheur c'est
d'avoir une nouvelle chose à voir un
nouveau téléphone d'avoir un nouveau
smartphone
une nouvelle application qui va apporter
de nouveaux services t'éclater avoir une
nouvelle bagnole une nouvelle télé une
meilleure télé profiter avoir toujours
plus
sauf qu'en réalité c'est pas ça alors
c'est quoi le bonheur qu'est ce qui rend
heureux mais qu'est ce qui rend
réellement heureux
quand j'étais petit mon grand père
disait le bonheur n'existe pas et myope
tas de petits bonheurs en réalité on
pense tous que le bonheur on peut le
trouver qu'on l'a le bonheur ça réside
pas dans le fait d'avoir un nouveau job
d'avoir une promotion
ça c'est important ce un cadre de vie
pour évoluer et pour s'épanouir
mais cela parce que tu as un nouveau job
un meilleur salaire une promotion qui
est plus heureux tu peut accumuler tu
peux voir beaucoup d'argent c'est pas ça
qui va te rendre le plus heureux mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait en réalité quand on
est dans une routine et qu'on se fait
chier on va chercher des palliatifs et
ça c'est un départ hâtif numéro un
patron nouveau téléphone tu es content
parce ça te fait un pic de bonheur tu
crois que tu es heureux effectivement il
ya un moment de satisfaction mais c'est
pas du bonheur c'est de la satisfaction
personnelle bout d'un moment tu finiras
par t'emmerder tu vas chercher une
nouvelle application
tu vas trouver un nouveau jeu tu vas tu
évadés et tu vas trouver un peu de
satisfaction ailleurs dont le fait de
gagner une partie sur un jeu vidéo dans
le fait d'évoluer gagner des points
mais en réalité une fois que ton
téléphone était éteint une fois que la
partie est terminée
qu'est ce qui est plus qu est ce que tu
as créé et qu'est ce que tu as vraiment
créé pour toi absolument rien
ce ne sont que des palliatifs pour
oublier que tu ne vit rien et pour pas
de faire chier parce qu'en réalité le
bonheur il est où le bonheur il est dans
l'émerveillement de chaque instant il
est dans le fait de partir de voyages et
de vibrer et de réellement vibrer sauf
que dans notre fonctionnement actuel et
dans notre façon de vivre
on a très peu de moments où on peut
faire ça ou on peut s'évader
on a la liberté parce que on a besoin
d'argent parce que si on travaille pas
on n'a pas d'argent on peut pas voyager
on peut pas s'évader
ça c'est une réalité mais en vérité il
faut vraiment s'ouvrir au monde
s'ouvrir aux autres et chercher du
bonheur mais du bonheur réel pas de
palliatif ça tu le prends tu jettes il
n'ya pas longtemps on a eu la chance de
partir en guadeloupe en famille j'étais
faire de la plongée dans la réserve
cousteau
c'était juste exceptionnel déjà le clip
de plongée j'avais envie depuis très
longtemps
c'était intense et le fait d'être
complètement immergée de voir des
poissons extraordinaire de voir des
choses que je n'avais jamais vu ça
c'était un instant de bonheur
pourquoi pas parce que j'ai eu une appli
et que j'ai vu des poissons magnifique à
travers mon april j'ai regardé une vidéo
et que j'ai pu découvrir des choses non
parce que j'ai vraiment vécu ça et que
ça s'est inscrit là ces instants là il
faut savoir les saisir
quand on s'est retrouvés sur des plages
paradisiaques en famille c'est important
de prendre un moment de s'arrêter de
regarder autour de soi et dire ah ça
c'est un instant de bonheur ça c'est
quelque chose de rare et c'est quelque
chose qu'on est en train de partager
savoir s'arrêter
16e instant le partager ensemble j'ai la
chance avec mon fils de savoir prendre
les moments on arrête on partage un
moment drôle on partage un moment où on
rigole mais si moment là il faut savoir
les garder il faut savoir les préserver
le secret du bonheur ça c'est ton niveau
de voleurs
ça c'est en en réalité quand tu vas
posséder un nouvel objet tu a possédé
par exemple un nouveau smartphone un
nouveau jeu ce que tu veux bon tu as
remarqué je suis pas très bien ça c'est
un smartphone son bonheur il va faire ça
tu parles en bas pas très heureux monte
et pour des cons si vite alors tels que
ça va durer peut-être que tu auras un
petit plateau
mais au final le bonheur ici tu perds
donc ça sont des bonheurs éphémères sont
des choses qui ne durent pas ça c'est de
la merde
le bonheur c'est pas de posséder c'est
d'être le bonheur c'est de vivre vibrer
partager voyager découvrir s'ouvrir aux
autres
s'émerveiller ce qui va voyager par
exemple en egypte tu t'es merveille
devant les pyramides
si tu fais de la plongée pour la
première fois ton premier baptême de
plongée pas les yeux écarquillés et en
prend plein les yeux
ça c'est des instants de bonheur parce
que c'est pas des choses que tu crois
posséder c'est des choses qui te
construire réellement pour être heureux
il faut jeter les palliatifs et prendre
le risque de s'ouvrir s'ouvrir aux
autres et s'ouvrir au monde et ça aucun
smartphone aucun jeu et aucune
application pourrait le faire à ta place
dis moi ce que t'en pense dit moi si tu
es d'accord ou est-ce que tu puisses ton
bonheur qu'est ce que toi tu penses du
bonheur qu'est ce que tu penses que
c'est où est-ce que tu le prends et est
ce que tu penses accorder suffisamment
de temps aux choses qui comptent et aux
choses importantes mais le mans
commentaire dis moi ce que tu penses si
ça te plaît tu mets un pouce et utah
bonne n'hésite pas regarde cette vidéo
et pour ta bonne et c'est en bas dans la
diagonale à bientôt et prends soin de
toi